er hat in deutschland den impfstoff
erfunden sie hingegen sollten den
impfstoff bloß bestellen er hat alle
seine mitarbeiter dafür rund um die uhr
arbeiten lassen sie hingegen haben
millionen deutsche dafür bezahlt dass
sie nicht arbeiten er hatte von anfang
an in der krise ein ganz klares ziel vor
augen sie haben dieses ziel in der
korona krise bis heute nicht gefunden
er hat den wert seines unternehmens bei
und hat gerade um 250 prozent gesteigert
sie hingegen häufen gerade massive
rekordschulden an wo stünden wir in
dieser corona krise eigentlich wenn ich
sie deutschland regieren würden sondern
eher trägheit langsamkeit bräsigkeit
deutschland ist schlechter als sein ruf
die korea-krise die zeigt uns gerade was
unsere regierung und unsere verwaltung
alles nicht können oder zumindest nur
sehr langsam können
deutschland ist nur mittelmaß die größte
leistung unserer regierung in dieser
krise millionen menschen dafür zu
bezahlen dass sie nicht arbeiten
das ist zu wenig damit möchte ich mich
nicht abfinden auch in der regierung
brauchen wir menschen wie ihn den bei
und ex-chef typen die schnell sind nicht
bräsig typen die sich mit mittelmaß eben
nicht zufrieden geben
typen die hoffnung machen